so beautifully written it's one of the
best screenplays I've ever seen and and
you know the first time I read it I was
initially supposed to direct this and I
read it and I just you know slobbering
and tears rolling down my eye and I just
called Kenny immediately and I said
Kenny you have to direct it I mean it's
just there's no other way that this can
be done I mean it's so unmistakably a
Kenny Lonergan movie and probably as a
producer the smartest thing I did was
getting out of the way I don't know
about that I mean this is a really
challenging movie to get made it's not
like other movies and and that means
that that's what makes it great but
that's also what made it really hard to
get it funded and we were really lucky
to meet Kimberly Stewart and her company
Kay period and we needed a financier who
was smart and who had great taste but
but also was really courageous because
you know the kind of margins we're
talking about now in the movie business
you have to have a lot of guts to get in
the game and and she really knew she
really got the script and understood
what was great about it and just and
just backed it to the hilt and and
that's why we're here
I'm thrilled for those guys I mean and
they really do deserve that
that kind of chatter I mean they're
really special performances and and it's
a special movie
I can't wait I think it's gonna be
awesome I think it's gonna be fantastic
I just wish Jerry Weintraub we're here
to see it yeah you bet they're gonna
kick ass